Speaker 1: We have a voicemail
number. That number is 2192. David.
Speaker 2: Thank you. Your lucky
stars every day. You're not Dave.
Speaker 1: Packman, but you can call
Dave Parkman at 2192. David P Here is a caller who
learning that I will soon be in Florida is asking
whether this is the trip during which I will eat
fast food with Farron Cousins. Listen to this.
Speaker 4: By David on the bonus show in London.
Yes. And you mentioned going to Florida for the
trip. I just want to remind you, if you happen to
be fair, then I just want to remind you that like
a year ago, he said he would. I think you said he
would get you McDonald's. Are you a Burger King?
I think it was just a fast food burger, basically.
But I remember the night he tweeted at you. So I
just want you to know that you would be good
hosts if there's ever some sort of progressive
equivalent to. You know, seatbacks or something.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I would love to co-host something
with Faron. So listen, I am going to be in
Florida, but I'm not going to see Faron on
this trip. I'm going to be a different
part of Florida doing some appearances,
including on the Patrick about David Show
and with Anthony Pompliano, of course,
all assuming it doesn't get canceled. As I
told you, Lex Friedman canceled our appearance
together last week, a very, very last minute. I'm
hopeful that next week's appearances in Florida
don't get canceled. My goal is not to have any
fast food while I'm in Florida. I am looking
forward to the restaurant's great food scene in
the Miami area. So I am looking forward to that
many Argentinean restaurants. I'm going to be
going to Argentinean restaurants, getting some
empanadas, getting a little Milanese. It's all
happening. But I hope not to have any McDonald's
or Burger King or anything like that. Is it
conceivable some kind of emergency could take
place? And I end up having no choice but to get
a double whopper? It's possible. It's possible,
but let's hope it doesn't happen. On today's bonus
show, Kevin McCarthy blocking Swalwell and Schiff
from the Intel Committee. We will talk about
it when I'm joined by producer Pat. Journalists
deaths jumped 50% in 2022, led by Ukraine and
Mexico. And Netflix is finally there really
doing it this time. They're going to crack down
on password sharing and we will talk about how
and why. And is it fair in all of these different
things, get instant access to the bonus show by
signing up at join Packman dot com. You
can use the coupon code 24 starts now to
get yourself a sizable discount and it will
be maybe the best bonus show we've ever had.
Speaker 2: Oh the bonus show where you
want to make money and everybody else
who makes money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: That's right. Money will be made
on today's bonus show. And I hope, Alex, I really
hope it is not money that I ever end up having to
pay someone in a defamation settlement. Let's
hope that that's the case. We'll see you that.